bite for bite this is the best eating
experience i've ever had on one of these
things
both of these pizzas are amazing pizzas
hey everybody it's nicole russell from
last dragon pizza and
welcome to peace awards on first week
east in the pizza world
no topic is more controversial than
chicago deep dish
is it the ultimate cheese and sauce
stuffed comfort food
or tomato soup in a bread book well
today we're going to find out if two
thin crust loving new yorkers have what
it takes to make a deep dish pie
fit for chicago native the one and only
sean
evans plus faraday from munchies is here
to make sure the judge's table stays
fair
and balanced i'm putting my own spin on
this challenge by whipping up a chicken
parm deep dish
but my challenger she's coming straight
out of brooklyn and i know she's going
to bring the heat
hey everybody i'm josephine from lenny's
pizza in bensonhurst brooklyn lonnie's
pizza has been in bensonhurst since
1953.
it's from the iconic movie saturday
night fever when john travolta comes up
to the window and grips a double deck or
two slices right on top of one another
a new york city part is something that
you're just able to take
hold and fold and just eat while you're
running your enrons
when i went to chicago i actually needed
a fork
a knife it was a casserole filled with
butter
and a pound of cheese definitely excited
about making
a chicago deep dish it's something i
never did and i'm also really excited to
try nicole's
pizza even though mine's gonna be better
you heard that all right duke's up
duke's up
[Music]
josephine i'm so stoked that you're here
you don't even understand i'm such a fan
so tell us what we're doing today we're
doing deep dish what you got going on
all right so i got a little spin we're
making a chicago deep dish
right but a new york style crust i know
you know what i mean you got it you got
it
i'm gonna make a jordan on pizza i know
there's a place in chicago
called giordano's it's my last name i
figured i'd make a part from there
because i'm kind of grandfathered in
maybe i could teach you my thing or two
oh listen i don't want to get that far i
don't want anybody knocking on my door
saying oh you're going to teach me how
to make pizza
[Music]
so right now i'm just taking the dough
and i'm trying to pull out as much
air out of the dough and pan as possible
okay
there's actually two layers of this
dough oh so you put
two pieces of doughs in there yes that's
pretty damn smart
it's a casserole
it's called a casserole they're gonna
kill her they're gonna kill me i told
you if they come knocking on my door i'm
not answering
yeah we're going to add some meats all
right try to distribute it evenly just
so that we have
a nice bite of everything i got some
sweet italian sausage i'm going to lay
it all out flat
right over the pepperoni so i'm just
adding a little bit of mozzarella this
is actually an east coast blanket
i'm adding an ample amount for a new
yorker but i know this might not be like
a huge amount for someone who's from
chicago
so i got peppers in i got some onions in
and now i'm gonna add some mushrooms
so you're just gonna like pack them all
in just pack it all in pack it all
in okay like a lasagna it's never gonna
be
a deep dish that was a lasagna it was a
casserole
i'm gonna add some sweet sauce my
marinade sauce
my father told me i had to bring this
all right so listen if you don't bring
this sauce
they're not gonna know what pizza is i'm
like all right fine i was gonna make a
sauce he's like no no you gotta bring my
sauce
this way everybody's gonna eat good i'm
adding some parmesan cheese to the pizza
right on top i mean you can never go
wrong with some parmesan parmesan makes
everything better
right and then i'm also gonna poke some
holes on top of this yeah so i can
breathe yeah and i'm also sending a
signal so these people think they're
going to come to my house guys
i can't take out the oven's at 4 25 i'm
gonna put this in for 25 minutes let me
help you darling awesome thank you
oh look at that beauty that looks good
i'm going to try to figure this out if
not
i want you to go down to the first floor
and i'm just going to flip it over you
stand there with a plate i'll just catch
it for you there we go for somebody who
never made
a chicago pizza you sure are a pro all
right
look at that okay awesome nicole look at
this one
right here it's good this one looks
great for you all right
enjoy it oh i can't wait amazing
look at that
this is really good it's so delicious i
like the way the onions are still so
crunchy and nice
yeah overall it came out great um it's
definitely a casserole
and uh it is what it is you know but
it's it's delicious
[Music]
okay josephine your casserole
blew my mind right in chicago pizza yeah
the chicago
i got it i'm gonna make a casserole tuba
okay but it's gonna be chicken parm
what do you think about that honestly
that's a great idea
all right well let's see so what i have
here is some chicken breasts
i have this brining in some buttermilk
right then what i'm going to do is take
this chicken
dip it in some flour egg bread crumbs
and fry it
oh it's coming out good that looks great
my inspiration
was lou malnati's and i know that he
uses a biscuit crust
and i love you know red lobster biscuits
so i always used to practice making
those biscuits at home so i kind of
wanted to make
a pizza dough biscuit biscuit-esque
kind of crust we'll see what happens are
you kidding i'm
so excited this is going to be real good
hopefully it works pray for me
i want to win but i love you i love you
too either way we're both winners
[Music]
okay so i have my dough here and i'm
just gonna start it out like i was gonna
do a pizza
but actually i'm just gonna roll it out
because in here is chunks of butter
and i'm gonna roll it out really thin so
then i'll get flakes
now that i got my pizza dough in the pan
i'm gonna start it off
by using whole slices i have some sliced
whole milk mozzarella and some sharp
provolone sliced also
so now i'm just going to toss this
chicken right in here and spread it
evenly
through the bottom and now what we're
going to do is
add a little sauce because you know i
feel like a good chicken parm
needs a little sauce on it i'm gonna add
some provolone cheese on top of that
that's gonna give it a little sharp kick
to it
i'm gonna add the mozzarella on top now
so now i'm putting the sauce right on
top of that mozzarella
nice all right and then finally what i'm
gonna do is
i sauteed some bread crumbs with some
garlic parsley
and some anchovy paste special sauce
give it a little crunch nice little
texture right definitely
all right it's ready to go in the oven
let's throw this in
all right
okay i'm gonna oh take this out
boom
i think it smells amazing well let's
give it a try
get some chicken yeah that's what i'm
trying to do i'm trying to get some
your chicken it's good
what do you think buena winner chicken
dinner
i think shauna liked it i mean listen i
think he's gonna love my pizza too
yeah he is it's really good now we gotta
go to the judges table
we've got sean evans from hot ones here
and we got faraday from munchies
so let's see what they think i'm ready
moment of truth
let's do it
sean faraday thank you so much for being
here thanks for having us yeah excited
to be here
sean let me ask you a question what
makes the best chicago deep dish pizza
well you know i'm a lover of deep dish
it's something that i crave you know now
living here in new york i get frozen lou
malnati's
sent to my apartment to me what makes it
good the golden brown
butter crust of it all and i think where
it can lose a little bit
is if it gets a little soupy i think
that's what separates
the good deep dish from the just okay
deep dish okay that's thorough i get it
it begs the question like
is deep dish pizza i think that it's
like a style of pizza we've got like
neapolitan you've got new york style
and i think that this is a style of
pizza it's got the sauce it's got the
cheese it's got the crust
despite probably a lot of people are
gonna be like no and disagree with me
i think that yes it's pizza i will
consider it pizza i'll take that
all right guys there's a deep dish right
in front of you josephine you're up
first
so what i made for you guys today is a
jordano's
deep dish pizza with a little bit of a
new york flair
we have some sausage pepperoni mushrooms
peppers
and mozzarella up in there and then i
have my
own lenny's pizza pizza sauce on top so
between all of it i'm winning sorry
all right i'll do the honors here oh
that's a nice cheeseburger it's a good
pull that's good i put extra cheese fish
on
yeah yeah i'm going right in oh crap
speechless that really was
um an experience that transcends eating
like i said i get deep dish delivered to
my place
it's something that i crave the the
regional chicago delicacy
i miss most when i'm not there i'm not
joking
up there in the pantheon of legacy
chicago deep dish pizzas absolutely
thank you
thank you great the thing that sometimes
i don't love
about a deep dish necessarily is when
it's like overly saucy and kind of like
all over the place that is something
that's also really fun about a deep dish
pizza
but i like that this kind of held
together really well i love
like sausage and peppers together and i
like that you brought in your like new
york flair
and it's it shows it's delicious you got
your work cut out for you i know
i know i did something a little creative
and i think you guys are gonna enjoy it
ready for some chicken parm deep dish i
like the way that sounds yes
well it looks and smells delicious i
can't wait to dive in here
yeah oh look at that you're holding it
with your hands that's
bomb i mean this is delicious and i do
love like the different textures
it's very cheesy it's the sauce is
delicious i like the crust i like that
it's very hydrated it's flaky
it's delicious into to like the texture
the way that you cut through it and like
there's the different kinds of crunch
as you work your way through oh thank
you so much
guys i've sat in seats like this before
and done
shows like this bike for bite this is
the best
eating experience i've ever had on one
of these things both of these pizzas
are amazing pizzas
[Music]
decisions decisions that's what's going
through my head right now
we don't have to agree right no we don't
maybe we should one two three go with
this and just like good idea
yeah yeah yeah all right so i think i do
have
my winner in my head i don't know like
give me one second yeah yeah yeah take
your time take your time
now i'm i'm getting sweaty my heart is
like beating out of my chest
[Music]
one two three nicole
oh my god
oh my god i always i almost was like the
last time you're like same with me
same with me like it really was that
close it is a
coin toss with this you know like
memorable
memorable pizzas you guys could open up
restaurants
in the 312. thank you you know that's us
they need to watch out
sean and faraday thank you guys so much
for being here too you guys are like
trailblazers
and it's an honor to have both of you
here today
and you know what make sure you tune in
again next week for peace awards
you